lance bass and husband michael churchian
are new parents the reason i wanted to
get married to this guy is i know he'll
be an amazing dad the couple welcomed
twins via surrogate a baby boy and a
baby girl lance and michael have been
married since 2014. that's right i got
twins on the way they could come any day
now et recently caught up with the nsync
star at the mtv video music awards take
a good look this is the last time you
see this guy arrested
so never be at the vmas for the next
just so you know aj works for either
baby
it's a great name leading up to the big
day lance shared his excitement about
spending the holidays with their
newborns what kind of final preps are
underway at the house for your new
little ones that are coming twins oh
girl it is it is crazy at this house
because we're in the middle construction
now um you know doing construction in
the middle of a pandemic is pretty
impossible to do so hopefully we'll have
the nursery done by the time they get
here if they come early we're in trouble
so uh
so i'm praying they they stay baked
until at least mid-october um
and but you know they're twins so we we
know they'll come early our due date's
november but they'll definitely come
before halloween which i'm excited about
because i am a huge halloween freak and
i need halloween babies you know
halloween christmas you name it you know
it kind of loses that magic the older
you get but then when you have kids
around and see that magic through their
eyes it just brings it right back and
i'm excited to feel that again lance and
michael first announced they were
expecting twins in june and it was
pretty obvious they already had
halloween on the brain
there it is again
there's something in this house
yep the couple filmed an elaborate fake
horror movie trailer for tick-tock
michael look
[Music]
lance and michael's happy news follows
many previous ivf attempts last fall a
surrogate was eight weeks pregnant with
a baby boy but suffered a miscarriage i
can't help but kind of feel for you and
michael and the journey that you guys
have gone on and you've been very vocal
about what's happened so how are you
guys doing uh
with everything involving that you know
we're still staying positive uh you know
we know that this process can be long we
have several friends that have gone
through ivf and
um you know it's
it's it's not as perfect as everyone you
know it's like you think oh it'll happen
first time it hardly ever you know works
the first time so we knew that going in
and we're just trying to stay positive
obviously this happy day has been a long
time coming the couple opened up to e.t
in 2018 about starting their parenthood
journey what is the the real story and
where you guys are at with that because
i know you'd be amazing
uh no it's something we're very excited
about i mean the reason i wanted to get
married to this guy is i know he'll be
an amazing dad um and we've been putting
off for a long time but uh this is the
year that we're actually starting the
process
and um and actually yeah i mean as just
last week
really started the process so we're
excited
[Music]
you